casting i want to learn because i said
the documentary last night and this is
real and she probably thinks
this is just a fad for me but it really
was scary
about social media and i i
i want to turn off all my notifications
i might even delete instagram and
twitter for a while yeah
it's good to take breaks yeah because i
find that my depression is very closely
associated with
um right now what's going on in the
world but it's
all skewed right and it's all
um you know because of these algorithms
and stuff it's like you and what i
learned from the documentary is is that
if i could google one thing all right
and if i googled the same exact thing if
i lived in alabama
a bunch of different things would come
up because it feeds into what order you
you liked before
or what like the the internet knows you
mean what your personal bias your
personal bias confirmation bias
so people get information in different
kinds of ways
which is why we have such a polarization
in this country
and it's like now it gave me some um
empathy for the other side it really did
you know because
you know if i'm getting one set of
information
and somebody's getting another set of
information obviously
it's gonna pit us against each other so
i just
at the end of the day i don't want to
get involved with any of it
yeah i totally and the fact that you
said you get you had empathy for the
other side is like
such a crucial point that's so hard it's
not as bad
it's horrible it's not as bad
as we think it is yeah you know and um
unfortunately it's like we are being
pitted against each other like via
our own country via other countries yeah
russia and iran and china
it's an um it's it's
it's really we don't disagree on as much
as we
think we do and you're not going to sway
somebody's opinion by going after them
on twitter
and um you know i mean at the end of the
day
how many calories is it worth burning on
trying to like
roast somebody on twitter for liking
trump or
the opposition right right and yeah it's
totally closely associated to my
depression
so the second i relieve myself or if i
spend time away from instagram or like
i'm not worried about who's liking the
photos or who's retweeting me
the more the better i feel ah yeah
absolutely i'm the same way
yeah and i it is such a source of of
not good feelings for me oh any kind
actually just being on my phone not even
necessarily being on social media
but even googling stuff even on my email
anything relating to uh for a gadget in
front of my face
it doesn't tap into like my natural
state of being at all it feels
very an abnormal connection
totally and i don't i don't like that so
when i'm away from it i start to feel
more grounded i start to feel like i'm
into in
in my own body again absolutely and and
the only problem
with it is like especially for what we
do
you can become irrelevant so fast if
you're not
posting on the daily yeah and so like
i've you know i made the decision to
kind of like pull back but at the same
time
you know you lose any sort of traction
you may have online and then like that's
affecting your income and
so you have to draw you have to like
make a balance with like i'm okay with
not being
in this grind all day as long as i can
be kind of happy because when i was in
the grind i was miserable
right yeah there's a direct that's a
good point there's a direct correlation
between
what i do for a living and social media
especially
now right so um in many ways
you still have to i mean i've never been
a big poster myself
you know i don't post a lot but still um
i still need to do it
every once in a while so it's just
something that i'm gonna have to figure
out as we go forward but um i think
there's a way
i think that i've i've there's i'm
starting to realize
what how i can use it in a way that does
bring some sort of joy into my life and
it's it's if i like what i'm gonna post
and if i don't feel obligated i always
ask myself do i feel obligated to do
this
do i really enjoy this content myself
like what's
and it's usually a bobby doing something
silly those are the things
and it brings it makes me giggle so then
i'm like okay i want to share this
yeah yeah so it's things that general
them really do make me happy that i post
now
versus before where it's like you know
tits out
didn't make me happy no comments made me
happy and now it's just like no
i'm just gonna put bobby's little happy
belly on there yeah speaking of tits out
so gonna tits out where's what happened
to your girl maybe
oh i so it's hard you know it's hard
good segue it's a breathable bobby asked
me
bobby asked me if i was in a
relationship when when i got here